So speaking about communicating with the
dove um you uh first met the crew in the
Amazon you talk about JJ as somebody who
can communicate with animals what do you
think JJ is able to see and hear and
feel that others don't that he's able to
communicate with animals when I say this
is the most skilled jungle man I've ever
seen and I know so many guys in the
region
um he has libraries of information in
his Cranium that we cannot fath it's
just it's just stunning like you know I
have seen him use medicinal plants to
cure things that Western doctors
couldn't cure I've seen him navigate in
such a way that he's not using the Stars
he's not using any any discernible you
know it's like when elephants sometimes
like you'll watch a herd of elephants
and they'll be like yo let's go we're
going this way and you'll see them sort
of communicate but there's no audible
sound they'll just decide that they're
going that when they all do it JJ has
this way in the jungle of you know he'll
stop and he'll go wait and you go what
is it and he goes
does it hurt a peckery coming and I'm
like where
based on what yeah you know and he's
like just wait you'll see and he'll sit
there
um yeah it's just experience it's
incredible experience it's it's it's
growing up Barefoot in the Amazon and
the gift is that he can speak fluent
English and so when I bring tourists and
scientists or news reporters down there
he can communicate with them he's
actually good on camera because he
doesn't care about cameras
um
and like you know for instance we were
we were we were walking up a stream a
few months ago and I went hey look
Jaguar tracks and he went oh and I was
like what Jaguar tracks and he's like no
look look harder and I was like
the toes are deeper than the back and he
was like uh-huh and where are they and I
was like by the water and I was like the
Jaguars drinking it was leaning to drink
and he was like that's right he's like
now look behind you I look behind me and
there's scat there's a big log of Jaguar
sitting there it's got butterflies
all over it fresh Pretty fresh and then
there's another one that's less fresh
and so he's he's teaching me as he does
he's going look at this look at this is
that one as fresh as this one no and
then he goes now look up look up
there's three vultures above us
the kill is near us the Jaguar has been
coming multiple times to the river to
drink as it's feasting on whatever it
killed and he's going it's within 30
feet of us right now and it's like
I'm like oh look impressions in the sand
he's like I just drew 19 conclusions
from that it's like watching Sherlock
Holmes at work it's just constructing
the crime scene incredible
[Applause]
does that apply also to be able to
communicate with the actual animals like
read into their body movements directly
uh into their whatever that Dove was
saying to you you'd be able to
understand or is that all just kind of
taking in the complex structure of the
crime scene of the interactions of the
different animals of the environment and
so on like what is that that you're able
to communicate with another creature
that he was able to communicate with
another creature he knows the intention
of pose he knows the habits he knows the
perspective when when when he talks
about animals he'll talk about each
species as if it's a person so he'll say
oh oh the the Jaguar she never likes to
let you see her and so he'll come back
from the jungle and go oh I was watching
monkeys in this I this Jaguar was also
watching the monkeys but I was being so
quiet she didn't see me and then when
she see me she feels so embarrassed and
she'd go and he'll tell you this story
like as if he had this interaction with
like his neighbor
and you know and he'll be like oh the
puka cunga it never does that you won't
see it do that and so one time one time
he caught a fish and I I was such a big
fish it was this big beautiful
pseudoplatistoma this tiger catfish this
amazing old fish and they're all excited
to eat it and I felt so bad watching
this thing gasp on the sand and I went
you know what we don't need this this is
for fun
and throw back oh no and then I took my
hand and I went
and I made like drag marks like so I
could say oh it it snuck back in the
water and so he walks up he looks at it
and he was like I hate you what no I
said I must have it must have just he
went that's not what happens he goes It
goes like this when it go he knew the
track of a fish and I was like oh yeah
I was like all right JJ I'm sorry I'll
catch you another fish
uh so stepping back to that way you open
Mother of God
yeah uh who was Santiago Duran what
secret did he tell you JJ's father was
uh at some point he was a policeman at
some point when he was a teenager he was
working on the boats that before this
little gold mining city of Puerto
Maldonado uh grew the only way to get
supplies in was to take canoes up the
temple River up to the next state which
is puno and and where the mules would
come down from the mountains with
supplies and then he'd pilot the boats
down but they didn't have Motors at that
time so he would be pulling the boat so
he was he became this physically
terrifying man and I met him when he was
in his 80s and he was still living out
in The Jungle by himself and I mean he's
seen an Anaconda eat a taper which is
the you know a cow-sized mammal in the
Amazon he'd seen uncontacted tribes face
to face he once killed an 11 foot
electric eel opened the back of the
thing's neck removed the nerve that he
says was the source of the electric then
he cut his forearm placed that nerve
into his forearm wrapped it with a dead
Toad and claims that it would give him
strength through the rest of his life
and continued to be a jungle badass
until the day he quietly leaned back at
a barbecue and ceased to be alive
the man was incredible but the secret
that he told us was
that if you want to find
big anacondas you know if you want to
see the yakomama he was like you have to
go to the boyo the place of Boaz the the
place that we came to call the floating
forest and so he sent us there and it
became like this
this pilgrimage and you know in the
Amazon the a lot of the creation myths
are based around the Anaconda coming
down from the heavens and carving the
rivers across the jungle and if you look
at the Rivers it looks like that it
looks like the path of an anaconda
crawling through the jungle it's even
the right color
and so from the reference to the tribes
of women the Amazons to the Anaconda
mother everything in the Amazon is very
feminine based even the even the trees
the largest trees in the jungle the
mother of the forest the Madre De La
Selva is the K-pop tree and it's just
this monster tree these beautiful
ancient trees and that was the beginning
of the transition that we made from me
being like I hate school I want to go on
adventures you know Jane Goodall got to
do all this amazing stuff I'm just a kid
stuck here
to to eventually becoming something that
had to do with where my identity became
the jungle where my life became the
jungle the the secret that he told us
opened that door because when we started
working with these giant snakes it
started getting attention
it started getting people to go what are
you doing
um and it started it started allowing me
to have experiences that that solidified
and nailed down the fact that this
wasn't just like a weekend retreat this
was this was something that that I was
born to do and gave you more and more
motivation to go in into these Uncharted
Territory
um of the yuck yakumama
which uh just a step back what nations
are we talking about here is there some
some geography what are we talking about
where is this so I'm in Peru yeah we're
in Peru and so which is a South American
Nation perus a South American Nation
Brazil has 60 of the Amazon which is
unfortunate because anything that
happens politically in Brazil has a
massive impact impact on the Amazon
Peru
has the Western Amazon and Ecuador has a
little bit of the western Amazon and
the Western Amazon is where the Andes
Mountains
the cloud forests which is a mega
biodiverse biome falls into the Western
Amazon lowlands and so you have these
the meeting of these two incredible
biomes and that's what makes this like
superlative incredible you know glowing
moment of life on Earth so yeah we're in
Peru in the Madre de dios which is the
mother of God which I always thought was
such a beautiful
you know the jungle is the source of all
life
and uh so we were with the essay ha
people and they belong to a community
that's called infierno which is given by
the missionaries who when they tried to
go bring these people Jesus got so many
arrows shot at them they just called it
hell
um and so so Santiago Duran helped unite
these tribes that were that were sort of
scattered through the jungle and get
them status government recognized status
as indigenous people so he was sort of a
hero he was sort of a legend for a lot
of the stuff he'd done out Barefoot with
just like a rifle and a machete in the
jungle he he had died he had 19 children
and the last one the the I think the
20th child that he adopted was a refugee
from The Shining path that floated down
the river and he just took him in and
you know this is this is just a guy that
was a you know everything he did like
when he died the whole the whole the
whole region showed up it was it was he
was somebody so just the fact that I
know him gives me Street Credit like the
fact that I knew him I can go like oh I
knew Santiago and people like no
I'm like yeah yeah so you have to get
integrated to the culture to the place I
mean in every single way which is which
is tough for you for the being from from
New York yeah yeah it may it could have
been tough but it was I took to it you
know the jungle they they were very uh
you know JJ's teaching me about
medicines and we were doing bird surveys
and you know taking data on macaw
populations and JJ was just like you
really want to like he goes you gotta
sleep and I was like I only have a few
weeks here I know I don't know if I'm
ever going to come back I'm never going
to sleep so we'd be out every night
looking for all the wildlife we could I
wanted to take photos I wanted to see
things and and then you know the
exchange came with that he was like you
know I'm terrified of snakes and I said
well I've always worked with snakes I
said I'll teach you how to handle snakes
and then we just had this like little
exchange and when I left after my first
time back in 2006
you know I said I said how can I help
and and they were like look you know
we're out here trying to protect this
this little island of forest that is
going to be bulldozed and and the more
people that you can bring the more
knowledge and the more awareness that
you can bring to this it'll help and so
really at that age at 18 years old I
sort of
started dabbling with the idea of that I
could be part of helping these people to
protect this place that I loved and of
course at that time that idea seemed
like too large of a dream or too large
of a of a challenge so that I could
actually impact it